hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm
just checking in on you
i'm checking in to see how you're doing
if you're a man i know you're doing just
fine
cause it's september 1st
and what does september mean
[__] goddamn nfl football
[Music]
give me a [__] life
oh i can't wait i actually woke up this
morning
i thought it was opening day today and i
was like to the [__] bills
i'm sorry did the bills play the [__]
rams to kick off the goddamn 2022 nfl
season is that what i'm thinking i was
the [__] standing on the bed
standing over my wife do you know what
today is
oh two one two ready break
she's like um it's next week
so why don't you calm the [__] down
that none of that happened it all
happened in my head
it all happened in my head and in my
head my wife was also excited for
football season but we know that in life
you can't have it all because when you
have it all then you appreciate nothing
okay it's the struggle
it's the struggle that makes you
appreciate just being able to sit down
for [__] half a second
and have a cup of coffee
you know
i married maybe stare out the window as
you eat a sandwich
right if anything you ever [__]
wanted was always there there would be
no joy
you know you're in the clouds
right you know no enough you don't know
if you're [__] up and
down so why don't we just sit back and
thank all the [__] in our lives
do you was funny today i dropped my
daughter off at school
and i was [__] trying to make a left
and this woman was trying to make a
right i'm like why isn't she [__]
going she was across me i'm like you
know
go right and i didn't see you know they
know that blind spot you have
with that piece of metal every car has
that brings the roof down to the hood
that's where the pedestrian was
so i started to go and then i saw the
pedestrian so i stopped
and then as the woman made the right she
was a woman of a particular age you know
that look that [__]
older women that are successful
you know what i mean
it's funny their hair looks like it's 26
their glasses are like 40 000 and then
their face looks like the crypt keeper
you know
big [__]
fake lips and [__] they just have this
look maybe it's an la thing they just
have this look when they make the turn
when i'm being and i admit i was being
overly aggressive right they had this
look that they do where they just sort
of
as they make the turn they're not even
looking where they're going they're just
looking at you and their mouth is like
sort of like not
it's like 50 slack-jawed they have like
this
is it [__] looking at you
i don't know maybe it's just me i i cut
off a lot of people i cut off so many
people actually have this population
broken down
into segments
i saw another woman today i was pulling
up to the red light and i just looked
over at her and she was i don't know
what the [__] she was eating
it's like a monster burrito or anything
like a breakfast burrito and i looked
over and i was just thinking what if she
looked at me and i just shook my head
you know just judging her
not that i would do that but just to do
it for the [__] joke
oh bill bill what if you weren't a [__]
what if you were just nice to people out
on the road i was nice today i was nice
today sort of
or whatever
my daughter was hilarious this morning
you know we have like this ongoing
battle with like the tablet
like i'm not into that [__] at all them
having phones them having tablets or
whatever but there is that thing where
they they have to know how to interact
with the [__] because you know
we live in this world
oh speaking of [__] witch
has anybody ever said that speaking of
[__] witch i like that and put that
on a t-shirt um
i forget where i was
i was either in buffalo or redding
pennsylvania
and
me and kenny
and dean
got on the elevator
and then this [__] robot vacuum
cleaner just showed up around the corner
like r2d2 like the thing was like you
know like as big as a toddler
and it was trying to come in and
couldn't get in so i'm trying to hit the
doors to close and this [__] little
[__] little
little [__] [__] robot overrode me
he was somehow tapped into the elevator
that i couldn't make it [__] close
like this little [__] decided
and i i gotta i gotta sit there right
i'm a guest in this goddamn hotel
you know when it was a human being that
vacuumed the floors they're like no no
go ahead go ahead i get it you got to
get on with your day this little [__]
entitled little [__] robot [__]
overrode me the human being okay one of
us made you it wasn't me
i know i'm not smart enough
do you know i'm not smart you little
robot kite is that why you're overriding
me
oh man
it just it's it
it was unsettling
the only thing that made me feel all
right is i could i could tip it over
if all of a sudden it came at me with
like a little skill saw if he went you
know like his hand went behind his back
and then it came back out now it was
like a saw you know like they're doing
like the cartoons
um
it was [__] and then the thing gets on
the damn
elevator and then it's like [__]
getting up in my my my space
like it's trying i don't know like read
me or something like that
and i was cursing that the whole way
down i was like get the [__] out of you
and i know god good and goddamn well
there's some [__] nerd
okay and some bunker and like goddamn st
louis that's where i think it's all
going down in st louis
middle of the country as the oceans
[__] raise up and all the rats drown
huh
all the liberals drown first it's near
the ocean
liberals like an ocean
they live on the coasts
right and as it raises up it raises up
and starts getting the red people right
first the blues
and all the red people are gonna laugh
ah that's that's cause that's cause
god's punishing you for voting for a
democrat right and then the [__]
water's gonna keep coming again oh [__]
it is his word that now he is gonna take
us
that is no longer him punishing the blue
people it is now him bringing us into
his kingdom because he made us in his
image
however they're going to spin it
no one will ever think it was the
[__] oil companies that every time we
came up with a cleaner bit of energy
like you know what andrew themeless well
i don't put it on him
but he's the one who told me i guess
nuclear [__]
energy is a great thing
in my whole life it was all the hippies
were like hey man like no nukes man like
keep it [__] natural man
they had them all over their little
[__] volkswagen uh little buses and
[__] and evidently that rhetoric was uh
from the [__] oil companies and now
i'm out here in l.a
all the water's drying up
and uh you know it's like 107 [__]
degrees out
and i don't know maybe we should have
gone nuclear nuclear nuclear is that i
say nuclear
nuclear i don't know how to say it
i don't know how to say it but anyway
this [__] robot [__] rides with me
all the way down
and i just had this urge
to uh
tip it over
you know and i think at first if you do
that and you [__] the thing up
at first it would be like vandalism
or damage like i want to know from the
eggheads out here that are [__]
working on this i didn't get through the
st louis thing
remind me i'll get back to st louis but
i think at what point
does tipping over some little robot
elevator [__] oh you want to come in
i'll put you on your [__] head you
don't have any wheels down there now
what are you gonna do
[__] [__]
[__] unbelievably anyways
at what point if when i do that does it
go from vandalism
to assault
you know
because we all know the liberals at some
point and be like those robots have
feelings too
that's what i'm gonna side with the
right going like
you know where they're just like i don't
trust those [__] things there's we
are playing god and all of that i will
be right
that's when i swing my other leg over
see i don't trust either one of you
[__]
i sit right on the fence right i sit
right on the fence if you want you know
i lean left when it's right i lean right
when it's right and i [__] try to
walk right down the middle of both of
you because cause because uh cause you
know what because i think i have it all
figured out
that's what it is
because i'm in my ego too
i'm in my ego right
and i think if you know if you elect
bernie sanders he's somehow gonna topple
all the banks cause all of these blue
and red [__] are just gonna play along
with them even though the even the blue
ones have sabotaged this goddamn
campaign
you know
i can tell you right now
trumpsters if he was running the country
and there was an insurrection at least
they would have gone to the right
[__] building
they would have gone to the federal
reserve which is where all those [__]
buffalo headed [__] should have gone
instead of the goddamn capital he saw
there was nobody in there i love how
they acted like all those politicians
ran out the back door they didn't run
out the back door they weren't even in
there
they were too busy scoping out the
property that they were gonna get in
[__] martha's vineyard you know how
those guys said what are they what is it
what's a senator make 175 grand 200
grand a year and all of these massive
gated community houses he made a lot of
money in the private sector
did he score huh anything he touched
turned to gold ah how did that happen
unbelievable
it's unbelievable the way these senators
and representatives could just predict
the [__] market in the private sector
um
i was a public servant i was a public
servant for over 35 years and somehow
i'm worth 37 million dollars
i made 200 grand a year
um
all right i'm off the [__] rails you
know what it was is i had a nice [__]
double espresso i got my orange here all
right oh billy big britches is back on
his diet
you know
and uh
i finally got time to get myself in
shape
we are literally in the final
bit of uh putting the movie together we
have a fun day today we get to go uh
start doing the music and then we're
gonna color it
uh we got one scene that we're gonna add
to throw in there that's gonna be fun uh
the two people i wanted to cast i got
uh
the fenway gig is behind me
it's [__] fantastic
you know now i can kind of do whatever
the [__] i want to do and then football
season is starting me what more honestly
what more do you need i know what i need
i need a robot-less world or at least
can i live in a world where if i decide
i don't want to be on the elevator with
this robot [__] i can actually
can you imagine if like serial killers
had that ability you see some shifty guy
coming down the hall and you're like i
don't want to ride in the elevator with
this guy
and you go to press the button and then
like the terminator it cancels it out
you know what's funny is i basically was
in an elevator with a glorified vacuum
cleaner and i'm already you know
it's a slippery slope man
right
um speaking of slippery slope
the new york yankees
i watched the game yesterday i'm
watching the yankees now uh i watched
the red sox but then i flipped back and
forth to the yankees because uh i'm
rooting for aaron judge i want to see
him break this record he hit his 50 at
the [__] bomb
to straight seta
um
the other night
uh
in a victory against the angels i
believe
and uh maybe they lost i can't remember
but last night i i put it on and it was
like all right they're up two to nothing
yankees are up two to nothing
and uh you know they're playing the
angels and uh you know aaron judge ought
to be coming up i don't know what inning
it was i just kind of watched like the
last four
the starter was doing great he went out
and then he went to the bullpen and you
know with the yankees the way they're
playing right now that bullpen i don't
know what the deal is that's when the
game gets exciting because
you know they could come in and shut
them down or they could you know i don't
know but it wasn't the pitcher's fault
last night
was uh throw to
basically this guy hits one down the
third baseline
and that guy who claims he didn't say he
was like jackie robinson he stabbed it
got up and he threw it i don't know if
it was rizzo on the bag but rather than
coming off the bag he tried to stretch
because it was to his right and it got
past him
and then that guy went to second base
and then the next play is a grounder
like a [__] uh should have been a
double play ball but uh
that guy was on second
but now that he's on second does that
change the way pitch i don't know the
shortstop boots it
two errors in a row
all right so it i'm not saying the first
one wouldn't have been like an infield
hit but if it was online i think no i
think he would have had it so it was a
throwing error this it's basically two
errors and then ohtani gets up
and i'm like wait a minute this guy
this guy is is the japanese babe ruth i
mean this guy can throw a [__] no
hitter or hit a home run let's see what
he's gonna do
and what does he do
like aaron judge he goes straight away
center hits a [__]
to make it three to two
and i'm like holy [__] but then it was
still like the seventh inning and i'm
like all right
yankees you know
the only down to run let's see what they
can do and the angels brought this guy
in who i can only describe is somebody
who looks like he'd either be hanging
out at a bowling alley
selling grass in the 70s or he's like a
total full-on like analytics guy
like total math team guy like he just
looked like uh
you know those guys that are just skinny
their whole lives and they had that
really [__] pronounced adam's apple
they sort of look like buzzards you know
and then they put the glasses on you
like oh it's a smart buzzard right
that's kind of what he looked like
so i didn't have a lot of faith in him
and uh he proved me wrong
and they won it was an entertaining game
so uh this is also another thing that i
love about
september is like baseball all the races
start like
you know getting tight and everything
like that and if your team's out of it i
just start watching the games that
matter or whatever i did see though the
line shot
um
that what's his face hit a grand slam
for the red sox
um
why the [__] is his name escaping me
he's like the guy that everybody wants
this not deborah's it's not story it's
not bobby darback it's the other guy
it's our shortstop well you know it'll
come to me i understand how my old brain
works now you know what i have to do is
not think about it and then just
casually glance at it out of the corner
of my eye and then the answer comes to
me sandra bogarts
see how that works it's what it is you
just say you know what it's when you
care
when you have an older brain and you
care you start to [__] panic and
everything starts [__] ping-ponging
up in your brain and then the second
you're like you know what i don't give a
[__]
your brain comes back you know like a
cat like hey
come on man don't be like that right the
idea pops back in your head
um
so anyway
uh i actually was at a newsstand the
other day you remember those things
and uh
i bought a couple of magazines i bought
this one on custom trucks that i thought
would have ford and chevy's
it just had it was all you know gm's
which i don't mind
like i love a square body i kind of like
the gmc better than the chevy because i
feel like chevy's like a little more
mainstream
like uh
like right now if i was gonna buy like a
truck for the whole family
i'd have to go gm
you know i would either get the denali
which is basically a four-door bronco or
blazer
or a suburban which i rented when i was
in boston and had like a 30 gallon
[__] tank and was claiming he could
drive 480 miles
on a full tank and i'm thinking like at
what like seven miles an hour um
but you know
chevy suburban four-wheel drive you know
it's kind of [__] nice but a little
sportier you go to denali
uh
yeah if i was going to pick up truck i
got to go f250 regular cab that's it
right there that's my [__]
okay and i'm sticking by it and then if
i bought a sports car i would buy the
porsche 911 targa with the t-top and the
metal roll bar and i would get it in
that [__] 1970s orange
because that's what every guy that was
balling in the 70s
they would have like those wild colors
um
now am i going to do any of that no
you know why because you can only drive
one car at a time and then if you get a
whole [__] bunch of them then it just
becomes this
this thing
this thing that you now have to go deal
with
i wonder if he can rent one of those
somewhere that's the way to go i rented
a porsche one time when i went out i did
a gig in hawaii
and i went to the pro bowl
what a [__] great weekend that was
and me and my wife rented a porsche
convertible total taurus
when we were in hawaii
that was the time
i started drinking those white russians
on the [__] beach before our flight
the [__] was i thinking i drank like six
of them
oh my god
i had like five at the beach and then i
drank one more
at the airport
and my wife was like what are you doing
i said this is the last few seconds of
my vacation
and she just she goes you know you're
gonna have a brutal hangover halfway
through this flight i was like i don't
care because i'm living in the moment
and uh we were both right i made the
right decision to live in the moment
and she was 100 right because i came to
about an hour left in the flight and i
was like oh
yeah it was like i might as well drink
like [__]
like whiskey flavored milkshakes it was
it was one of the one of the worst
hangovers i had one of the uh uh
ones i don't care to remember
um
can we talk buffalo bills for a second
i didn't know they signed vaughn
[Music]
i mean i can't even tell you how [__]
excited i am
about the afc this year
all right
i mean look at look at the the [__]
goddamn quarterbacks
the quarterbacks that we have in the afc
this is the future
i'm calling it right now i think
i don't know
i don't know enough about the defenses
in the nfc
but i just i just
dude look at the [__] afc west
there's just four
[__] studs
at quarterback
and i'm thinking to myself hey bill you
didn't book any [__] in the fall
i'm gonna start going to some los
angeles charger games
because
patrick mahomes is coming to town
derek carr's coming to town
uh russell wilson is coming to town and
for some [__] reason
i can't remember the san diego guys
quarterbacks uh
herbert right
not dustin
christian
dakota
wait
chargers
i've already done this
qb why can't i remember this guy's name
herbert yeah it is herbert
justin not dustin justin herbert how fun
are those [__] games gonna be all
right then you got joe burrow
and you got josh allen
that is four six
who else do we got and we're gonna see
what mac jones is all about
coming back for his third year
i don't know i'm really uh
i'm really excited i'd like to afc
[__] west is going to be
sick and then i
hopefully your bills you know be amazing
as if the bills play
who the [__] do we play this year what
division do we play hang on a second
hang on a [__] second
patriots
schedule
[Music]
20 not home you [__] well people okay
all the ravens oh we're going with that
division
is that what you're telling me
no wait we play the raiders
we play the raiders we got the steelers
the packers browns jets patriots sorry
jets bills
raiders
dolphins
oh that's our home schedule
no it isn't
oh we're playing the bengals too [__]
that's at home
wow
[Music]
and then we're playing uh what is it the
afc
the nfc west
wait cardinals vikings wait who are we
playing lions no we're playing the
central then we just have a random game
with arizona
we got the panthers which is gonna be uh
baker mayfield
tour with the dolphins
that skinny gentleman there for the
ravens i don't know who's with the
steelers now derek carr we got we got
some quarterbacks we're going up against
they got lynn dickey out there in green
bay aaron rodgers
then they got the guy who likes to go to
the massage parlor
for the browns
this is gonna be fun it's gonna be a fun
ass year i can't wait and then we also
have college football this weekend
what are you guys thinking about usc and
ucla going into the uh
into the uh
the pac-10 not the pac-10 the big ten
i don't know
from what i heard what those teams are
gonna do is
when they have a travel game they're
just gonna go they're gonna have
back-to-back weeks they just stay out
there
so they're gonna go out there and then
practice you know play the first game
and then just stay out there and then
play the next one so they're literally
on the [__] road like a baseball team
they're gonna have to pay
pay these kids
and you can have like [__] holdouts
and [__]
it's gonna be a nightmare i don't know
how you're gonna do it but what's funny
is how all these other [__] like
sports that barely buy
anything for the school like who's kid
and who all right your football and your
basketball program is why you have your
campus
that's basically it at all the big
schools
all right nobody gives a [__]
about your [__] rowing team
oh whatever um
so then and then it's going to become
like well how come the guys are making
more money than the women they're
literally going to do that and they're
going to completely ignore ticket sales
um so here's the thing though ladies you
have all the power here
if you want female athletes to make more
money or to make the same amount of
money you i said this is my last special
all you have to do is go to the games
you go to the games and you start buying
some [__] merch
if you women actually gave a [__] about
each other
okay
if you if you guys started doing
togetherness
rather than whatever the [__] it is that
you've been doing that you then blame
memed for
um
which you know we probably pitted you
against yourselves but you're also
smarter than we are so like
you've figured it out
now act accordingly
it's just more fun to fight all right me
undies everybody
do me undies me undies go watch women's
lacrosse do do do do me undies
me undies then you'll be the [__]
boss
but you don't want to watch those broads
you'd rather watch the guys
and have someone else pay for your
drinks and that's why you [__] always
stink and you're not gonna make the
money we do but you're wearing me undies
on your [__] clam all right meundies
you know we've all heard of gut instinct
but have you ever heard of butt instinct
it's when your butt tells you it wants
new me undies listen to your butt
you don't give a [__] okay luckily we
work with my undies makers of the most
buttery soft and sustainable undies
bralettes and socks that exist if you've
ever tried them before it's a great time
to start if you've never tried them
before sorry it's a great time to start
because they're currently offering their
best deals in years
right this is trending right now on
financial underwear dot net
uh get 20 off your first purchase with
free standard shipping and free returns
when you go to meundies.com
let your skin
sing a song of joy with undies oh my god
my tate feels wonderful
socks and bralettes that feel as if
they're spun from silken clouds
guaranteed to be the softest stuff
you've ever felt in your life their
signature micro modal modal fabric is
sustainable breathable and stretchy as
heck
stretchy is good but in the long run it
doesn't help you
believe me i thought i was still a 34
inch waist oh boy until you go into a
haberdashery place
and they don't have the stretchy [__]
you're like what do you mean i'm a 40.
uh available size in sizes extra small
to 4xl they have new colors and prints
dropping weekly so there's always
something exciting to check out try
their free to join membership for free
shipping on every order and exclusive
perks like an item shipped to your door
every month secret sales
and every x in early access to their
newest stuff to get 20 off your first
order in free shipping and 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
meondees.com
that's meundies
slash meundies.com b u r r herr
all right
and lastly but certainly certainly not
leastly
uh roman everybody
you know
how when you're wearing a great outfit
everything just looks right and your
confidence is soaring you can walk into
a room knowing you're on your a-game if
you've been struggling with pe
penis
no premature ejaculation
physical education roman can give you if
you're not getting picked in gym class
roman can help you
um
with roman hgh for eight-year-olds no if
you've been struggling with performance
no
premature ejaculation roman can give you
that same feeling in the bedroom
what
oh i missed the first part of it you can
walk into a room knowing you're on your
a game if you've been struggling with pe
roman can give you that same feeling in
the bedroom
that's not that's not written well uh
fitness look we all know that change
doesn't happen without action whether
you're looking for gains at the gym or a
better experience in the bedroom there's
never any shame in showing up for
yourself and your health so if you're
dealing with pe don't ignore the issue
instead face it head-on no pun intended
with roman
okay you make your dick stand up for the
national anthem all right
instead of laying there like some
[__] hippie that doesn't want to get
a job
uh
why do we have to work that's just a
social construct i don't know what that
expression means i just know you say it
when you're complaining with long hair
you said some points say social
construct uh general all right guys
man-to-man i care about each and every
one of you i want you to feel confident
and to prioritize your health and your
relationships absolutely get a flat
stomach and get along with your broad
all you got to do is caress them and say
that they're right just do that in the
morning
okay
and then you have a healthy breakfast
but the big thing is the morning you
caress the woman you're with and you
just tell her she's amazing and thank
her for being with you even if you're
not feeling it you just do that it keeps
them calm all right and they they stop
nitpicking maybe you can put on your
[__] jogging pants and uh go go for a
run around the block
you're going to the gym i want to go 40
minutes later
uh if you're ready to do that for
yourself start with roman entertainment
we have a lot of fun around here on my
channel podcast slash show so i know
that if you guys are anything like me
you probably dread wasting time in
boring waiting rooms then having to
spend money on a co-pay then insurance
it's a [__] hassle man you know how
it goes for my guys out there dealing
with uh premature ejaculation
or maybe just loving too much why don't
we just call it that if you're suffering
from loving too much
i have to tell you about roman roman
swipes are clinically proven to help you
last longer in bed no prescription
needed uh pe treatments are safe
affected and used by millions of men
free two-day shipping go to
getroman.com today if approved you'll
get ten dollars off your first order
that's get roman r-o-m-a-n for dummies
like me dot com slash burr all right
everybody that is the podcast
enjoy
the greatest part of the year
september the kids go back to school
they act like they don't want to go back
to school but they got their new clothes
on remember how exciting that is they
get to see kids they haven't seen all
summer
football starts baseball means something
um
and uh then next month hockey and
basketball start
then you got halloween
right you got some pumpkin bread then
you go into thanksgiving and then into
christmas
or kwanzaa oh
oh whatever the [__] it is you're into
then you have the saddest of all
new years
there we go again hit the reset button
and you fight off the fire let's not get
into that um all right
enjoy the music picked out by the uh
always brilliant always wonderful
always you know not dipping into his
trust fund andrew themless
i love how that's become like this thing
that he's this trust fund
kid i'm just riding with verzi on that
one and we have a bonus episode of the
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast will come right
after this
from a thursday
a while ago all right that's it
go [__] yourselves no enjoy your weekend
and i will uh i'll talk to you on monday
enjoy the college football all right
we'll see ya
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday september 1st
2014.
[Music]
eat some [__] [__]
fat tits fat tits fat tits you guys
ready huh football season
time to stop working out everybody the
summer is over
the summer is over time to watch people
in way better shape than you making way
more money than you as you get fatter
and dumber
i don't know about you guys but i can't
[__] wait
okay
i'm putting away my little speedo
[__]
bathing suit for the rest of the summer
i am now taking out my football [__]
my jerseys and my stupid [__] hard
hat that i put the construction you know
i don't do construction but i have a
[__] logo on the side don't you hate
that somebody did that back i think the
steeler fans were the first ones to do
that and they actually were building
bridges and they actually worked at
construction sites
then after a while you just kind of look
at somebody going like is that a foreman
i don't think is that an account i think
there's an account
is that a fake [__] construction head
um
anyways i'm so [__] beyond excited
that it's football season it's been a
while it has been a while since i got
this excited
and i watched a little bit of college
football i did my usual uh
rooting against i don't even know why i
root against alabama i i don't i don't
really not like them
i'm a [__] you know i'm a guy from
massachusetts where do i get off not
liking
uh the alabama crimson tide
however you [__] say it crimson tide
you know i just somehow fell into with
lsu
and i missed every second of that game
because i was doing the wonderful
oddball tour but uh
i uh
i guess they went down by 20-something
and they came back and won so um
that's great that they did that but
that's not really an impressive way to
start
you know against boring-ass [__]
wisconsin
what do they do run the ball to death
i'm just [__] with you wisconsin all
right i just wanted to get you up off
the couch away from that giant [__]
cheese block or whatever the [__] it is
you're doing
okay
sitting there with his and her cargo
shorts on
um car guru i can't talk [__] you i just
got off a plane and i ran home to do
this on labor day happy labor day
everybody
um i hope you [__] um
i hope you're not listening to this
right now because that would mean that
you're out with some friends and [__]
right
unless you listen to this later
at which point you know
maybe you had a falling out
maybe you finally just [__]
broke it off with somebody
and i don't even mean
in like a romantic way
like you had a romantic relationship how
about you just [__]
get rid of a friend there's a great new
year's resolution to make in september
september 1st isn't it the chinese year
new year or something the year of the
oscillating fan whatever the [__] it is
i don't know
um
that's a great thing to do
especially after i don't know depending
how old you are
if you've had friends for a long [__]
time this there's got to be one of them
you got to be like you know what i'm
just sick of your [__] i'm sick you know
what i'm sick of the ride
it's the same [__] ride and it ends
up with an apology as you're pulling
into the station up oh dude i'm sorry
blah blah blah blah and then when you
should get off the ride you don't you
stay on
and here we go again going up the hill
everything seems good everything seems
good and they [__] cross that line
again all right then you go around the
[__] roller coaster that's the big
goddamn fight and then you're pulling in
yeah you're right i'm sorry you know
i've just been going through some [__]
lately
and then your forgiveness says it's okay
and you get back on the [__] ride
again
get off the [__] right
is there a talk show about that
there's all kinds of talk shows about
romantic relationships but is there
anything out there that just talks about
i guess that court tv is friendship's
gone wrong
no stupid tv judges sit there screaming
at everybody because they're trying to
get you to quit flipping channels
what is it about watching somebody
getting yelled at you just have to stop
and watch
i hate those judge shows i don't care
about the people i don't care about
their [__] problems
and how you know he took one of the
[__] pickets out of my fence
so i threw some dog [__] over his fence
and then he [__] pissed in my car i
mean i mean they're not even that
compelling
you know dumb it down
to the level of my act and that's
basically what's going on and then at
some point somebody talks and then the
judge has got to start
screaming and yelling
i hate how they have the actual
authority still of a judge
you know what i mean
you shouldn't
it should be like optional whether you
listen to them or not and i don't give a
[__]
all you people out there right now going
well actually you know judge wapner was
actual judge and all these people
actually i don't give a [__]
all right
the second you're on tv you're not a
judge anymore that's like the old-timers
game for judges you know like one right
before the all-star game right they'll
have an old rod carew will come out and
all the greats you know when they're
swinging the bat and they can barely
[__] run because they're in their 60s
that's the same thing with these judges
once you go on tv you're not
you're not your job anymore i don't
think unless you're in show business and
you were dancing monkey from your first
[__] open mic
like what's his face
the guy who looks like a [__] cop
from the 1970s dr phil
a crooked cop at that right that guy
he's not a therapist
he's not a therapist anymore he is a
[__] tv star with groupies
right cocaine if he wants it it's not a
therapist
i don't even know what i'm talking about
i don't know how the [__] i got onto
this thing all i know is it's labor
labor day
okay and i and it's this is this is the
perfect [__] holiday to set off the
football season
you know one day a week that one game
that [__] counts they all count
because there's only 16 of them so
they're all important two-game losing
streak you're you're in trouble
right
those football players have been working
out
all goddamn summer to get into peak
physical condition and what better way
to honor them than just sit down and
just completely blow out your [__]
body that's what i plan on doing
sick of this [__] working out [__]
i want to [__] i want to grill
that's what i want to do for the whole
football season i'm going to [__]
grill something different that's what i
i would like to do
eat like an angel all [__] week right
with my little button nose you know
my dreamy eyes
i'm just going to add another compliment
to every physical thing that i have
um
no i shouldn't say dreamy eyes i gotta
make it easier for you guys my confident
forehead
[Music]
i know what that means
um
anyways
that's what i want to [__] do
and uh
i actually have a little bit of time off
this year
because uh
i just decided to take some [__] time
off
you know because i get the nfl package
every year but it's usually like today
like i'm flying back from the [__]
road i already know what happened and i
sit down and i can sort of fast forward
my way through the game but i don't get
to go through the whole emotion of it
and then that type of [__] so this year
this [__] yeah i plan on doing it
i plan on doing it so i don't i don't
really know what's going on in football
the game i watched i watched uh
i watched west virginia
versus alabama and i really resent the
highlights of that game where they just
keep showing alabama scoring
when there wasn't some major concern
going on down there in tuscaloosa there
as i tweeted for those of you following
me on twitter
um that was a close [__] game
and uh i didn't see lsu but i imagine i
wouldn't have been impressed with them
either if they got down by 20 something
i don't know what the [__] they were
playing
oh wisconsin that's right i brought it
up um
but uh i know is it me but that was sort
of supposed to be a cupcake game for
alabama and they uh
i don't know
hey by the way is lane kiffin uh
whatever his [__] name is is he
associated with alabama i wasn't sure
the first 58 [__] times they showed
that guy what was the big [__] deal
you know
he had he had a great job at tennessee
he told them to go [__] themselves i'd
rather be out here in usc
you know tagging some hollywood [__]
then he went to the [__] raiders and
now he's back there he gives a [__] he's
a coach
you hang around long enough you're going
to get fired or whatever or if you're
smart enough you leave early that's the
game i want to see i want to see when
alabama
goes up to tennessee it's the first time
lane kiffin
uh has been there since he [__] left
now for those who don't watch college
football they take it really seriously
down there in the south
especially in the sec
and by the way they got this great
commercial now how they swept all the
awards
any [__] major award that you could
be that could be won last year the sec
did it that's never been done by any
conference and they won the [__]
national title
so i think they have bragging rights
straight across the board and everybody
else has to pipe down
but uh so anyways they take the [__]
real seriously so out there in knoxville
tennessee for those who never been there
it's in the eastern part of the state it
is on east coast time
okay
if you're thinking about driving from
zanies in nashville to drive over to a
[__] game you will lose an hour
okay
and you might miss the beginning of the
game but you can still drive back and
make your show all right
um although i never did it it was just
gonna be too much of a [__] thrash
but that is one of my bucket list games
i want to go to that stadium with the
purina cat chow [__] uh
you know
end zone painted never going like dude
you don't want to go out there i know
this guy from tennessee right and he
[__] said their animals don't go out
there and it's just like what the [__]
gonna happen to me i'll put on a
tennessee hat
and i'll just [__]
whatever they say i'll just say it too
like some guy oh no
i'm like that's right buddy you [__]
know it you [__] know it
give me some of that yeah
and then i'll just keep walking in
nobody's gonna [__] with me
i just want to go see it so anyways
lane kiffin was the head coach
at tennessee now tennessee has had sort
of up and down but i mean generally
speaking is a respected program as far
as i know and what i know of it was
since you know peyton manning was there
so i don't know [__] about it so i'm
going to talk about it without knowing
and all you people in knoxville can tell
me what a dumb [__] i am and i don't
give a [__] as long as you listen as
long as you listen
so anyways uh
so he goes there and he's going to turn
the program around
right
whatever that [__] they all sound the
same right
that's all the same [__] song
um
so anyways he's going to go there he's
going to turn this [__] program
around and then all of a sudden usc i
don't know where you know he probably
gave the big long speech you know i'm
going to turn this program around
tennessee's had a long
and storied history of uh winning
and uh i plan to restore that blah blah
blah so all these [__] knoxvillians
okay they're out there shining up their
smokers
they're buying extra tins of chew
they're creasing the visor on their hat
even farther they're getting an extra
oily rag in their back pocket they are
[__] in
they have bought into the lane kiffin
era whatever is [__] there i'm
probably saying it wrong i don't give a
[__]
um i should probably look it up uh lane
kiffin right and then out of nowhere
in the middle of the night he accepts a
[__] job
with uh with usc and he just [__]
leaves
and i guess that was really embarrassing
for everybody in tennessee because
they didn't they they don't they view
their school as a destiny school for a
coach like they're being head coach of
the volunteers should be your dream job
we have won enough games we have done
enough things that we should be able to
hold that status and he treated him like
a stepping stone
you know
like some [__] he was banging on the
side and then his [__] wife called
and he [__] comes running home
so basically they can't stand this
[__] and um
so the way i said i wouldn't get in
trouble when i went out there because i
would just wear a tennessee hat and have
an affected accent
you know and they wouldn't give a [__]
they'd be so drunk they wouldn't notice
they wouldn't look and be why is this
german irish guy
talking like he's on hee haw it wouldn't
register they'd be like i [__] love
this guy man look at him
redneck he's a [__] red head man he's
even
deeper than we are
um
but lane is going to go back and he
can't do that [__] he's got to come back
wearing alabama he's got to wear alabama
[__] colors
you know that team named after the
detergent
i thought that they you know something
if west virginia
had converted on a couple of more plays
like that [__] game
could have gone the other way which you
can also say about alabama i mean that
one poor kid he dropped like a 50-yard
bomb it was right in his hands
um so i know you can say that but uh
it was way closer than the way that they
showed the highlights but anyways i'm
really excited uh that that
college football is back and i'm psyched
to watch sec football
i [__] love it it is the best and i'm
also excited to see other
conferences to try to dethrone them okay
so that's what happens on say
[Music]
on saturday right and then on sunday you
got you got pro football
pro football it's such a great time of
year and then
you also got baseball the games are
starting to matter like i'm actually
starting to pay attention to my my
[__] my d my detroit tigers oh billy
bandwagon
is a detroit tigers fan why why you ask
because
i bought in half on red sox season
tickets this year and i lost my [__]
shirt i know i live out here but it's
the [__] red sox they just won the
world series and i'm thinking all right
whatever i don't [__] go to i can
throw them up on stubhub all right and
someone will buy him and i'll at least
break even
but when your team just never gets they
never got going
this whole year
i don't give a [__] how bad your team is
at some point they put together a little
bit of a streak
gives the fan base a little bit of hope
it never [__] happened and
um
oh [__] this is andrew talking about the
[__] podcast
all right no worries i'm sorry i just
got a text
anyways and they never got going and i
just lost my [__] shirt so
last game of the year i have tickets
it's gonna be derek jeter's last time at
fenway park now
i could sell those two tickets and make
some of my money back or i could go back
and pay my [__] respects to one of
the best baseball players i ever saw
both on and off field the whole way
conducted ambassador the [__] game so
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna fly
back to the game now
if the yankees don't make the playoffs
that is his last game he ever [__]
plays
however
if the tigers [__] the bet
i think that they got a four and a half
game lead because they got one game one
game at hand
uh they played one less game i should
say one game in hand i guess is uh game
in hand is hockey but whatever
um
if they [__] the bed then the yankees
they get in and then it kind of it's not
as big a moment so i'm not being a
yankee hater here i just i'm being a
selfish fan where i want to go to his
last game ever
see his last at bat
um
i mean that's that's some that's that's
some legendary [__] right there you know
and i always show ted williams last at
bad at fenway or whatever so this is
probably the biggest last at bat
in fenway i'm trying to think of uh
come on one of you guys who plays in the
baseball fantasy league one of you stat
guys
who's other than ted williams who had
the most famous
last at bat
like i mean obviously you'd guess of big
time red sox i'd say the next biggest
red sock after him would be uh
karya stremski
unless you want to count babe ruth's
last [__] at bat
before we sold them
to the [__] yankees oops
um
hey he's kind of fat you know i don't
know
you know he's drinking all the time look
we want our three whatever he's gonna go
down to that [__] [__]
go down there he [__]
to the yankees they share a stadium
dude you realize the before babe ruth
came there the yankees were like the
jets
you know where the jets played at giant
stadium the yankees played at the polo
ground which was the giant stadium
and then babe ruth comes down there
all right and next thing that's why they
call it the house that ruth built as far
as i know as far as the drunk people
that i've been talking to in sports bar
i bought sports bars i think that that's
how that's how the story goes
um
so anyways there you go
there's your [__] sports talk
for the week all right now let's get to
uh
let's get the pain for the downstairs
here uh dollar shave club everybody
okay
we'll get to the other ones later
just set this thing up here um all right
let's talk more about so this weekend i
had such a great time i did the uh the
oddball tour remember that the oddball
slash pay for billy's basement here
um
it was just a great time man anytime uh
you know i don't get to see those guys
everybody that i toured with and uh you
know we went out we had drinks i don't
even remember where the [__] we were
we were somewhere in michigan
they booked us at these amphitheaters so
like you know
they're gigantic so they need gigantic
parking lots so not they're not really
in major cities
so um
i landed in detroit
and uh i [__] love that city man i
really love that city i swear to god
i swear to god
i want to find a couple of investors and
i just want to buy a block
you know
just buy a block of it you redo it
you just make it some late night [__]
a couple of clubs
no no but you need a grocery store to
make people move in
that's what that's why i for years when
i looked at cleveland and i looked at uh
detroit buffalo is not as bad but even
like buffalo you just look it's like all
it's going to take is just these [__]
buildings they're beautiful
i don't know but every time i get there
it gets a little bit better so every
time i go to detroit it's a little bit
better cleveland's like [__]
there's all kinds of building going on
there man i like all of those i like all
of those um
cities a lot like i don't know what it
is
i don't know if it's because my family's
from the midwest and we drove out there
a few times but there's something about
the midwest i really like it
and um
so anyways we performed down there um
wherever the [__] we were at
i don't even know i can't i can't tell
you the name of one venue they were all
like the
you know named after some cell phone
company
but the the crowds were just amazing
absolutely amazing the whole weekend and
i really got to see uh
you know
just working with you know some of the
best comics in the country some of the
best upcoming guys some of those ones
that are gonna be the guys you know
um
we all went out drinking dude i [__]
went out drinking in detroit oh that's
right we stayed at the mgm now it's
coming back to me
and i was
riding back in the van
with nate bergatzi and
he got wind of like saying
hearing that i said on my podcast that
golf wasn't a sport and dude the whole
way back
into the bar
through the second round of drinks we
argued
about whether or not
it was a sport or not and he he brought
up nascar
he said those guys are athletes i'm like
dude
i'm not saying
that somebody who drives a nas a nascar
vehicle
is not an athlete but you don't have to
be
you don't have to be a [__] any sport
like i said any sport where you can
throw like a girl
then it's not a [__] it's just you
know
you don't have hand i cord somebody
throws you a ball and you [__] tense
up and it bounces off you like they just
threw it against the wall
i know guys like that and that they're
still good drivers i'm not saying that
they're nascar level but
to me
okay as much as it's an insult i'm gonna
get myself in trouble again here as much
as it's an insult to golf a lot of
people would say that i say it's not a
sport i think it's an insult to nascar
to just say it's a sport
because like the nasa level [__] that is
going on in pit row that's the funniest
thing about going to a race
is if you're if you're in the stands
right across from pit row the level of
intellect
that's across the track
trying to figure out basically how to
make these rockets that don't leave the
ground
go like a [__] tenth of a mile faster
than somebody else and you're talking
they're going like you know 180 200
miles an hour whatever the [__] they do
now with the restrictor plates
and if you go right across the track
it's guys like me like
sitting there with a cooler
eating bologna [__] sandwiches
i don't know i i think it i actually i'm
not i'm not [__] on nascar i i think
it's a [__] insult to say that it's a
sport
um i i don't think so
all right and also the fact
of where it came from that it basically
came out of like bootlegging
during prohibition
and having like a stock car you look at
a car and you think it's just
stock from the factory but you got under
the hood you know you
i love that [__] that's why i was
talking last week i love that
mercedes-benz station wagon
but it comes from the amg factory so go
you know whatever zero to 60 in 3.5
seconds but people think you know you're
going to the grocery store i love a
[__] sleeper
so um
i'm not disrespecting nascar
by saying that it's not a sport i just
look at it i think that's an insult
to to racing to say that it's a sport
you know
because as great as basketball is at the
end of the day you're putting a ball
through a hoop
all right as great as hockey is you're
trying to put a [__] rubber disc into
a net
you can do that with all them for four
major sports what they're doing
is is an entirely different level like
they're
changing what's possible
in in in transportation like
i don't even know how to say it i'm too
dumb to say you talking like like the
amount of like physics the technology
that is going on
i don't know
i would say it's closer to transformers
than it is a sport
but whatever so nate is just sitting
there like
flipping out he and his argument about
golf is what everybody says about how
[__] hard it is and i just keep going
like dude just because it's hard doesn't
mean it's a sport
algae but to intrigue was really hard
for me i didn't think it was a sport
i also don't think just because there's
a [__] ball it makes it a sport
either
all right so whatever i'm going to have
nate
i'm going to have nate borghati on my
podcast because it was such a [__]
long argument and then we got into the
whole nascar thing i'm gonna have him on
here and plus you guys should know about
him because he's a [__] phenomenal
comedian
um really one of my favorites
that's coming up um
i worked yeah just a lot of really funny
guys
hannibal burris that whole [__]
generation of guys michael che all of
those guys are [__]
hilarious and um
the next night we went to
pittsburgh
and pittsburgh is one of my favorite
cities out there
um
it just sucks now when i go there i'm
only there for one night so i think next
next year as i'm putting together my
[__] hour
i might do a little three four day run
there
there's always something you know what
i've always wanted to do there i always
wanted to take that [__]
whatever the hell that is that tram up
that hill that you see every time i go
there i look out my hotel window i'm
like there's that goddamn thing i always
say i'm gonna go up there
those [__] illuminati houses looking
down on the city like we we run [__]
like they have the power switch switch
up there and they're gonna flip it
whenever they want to if people get out
of line and shut everything off
um
and then the last one we did we did
outside of uh chicago it's another
[__] unbelievable city
that i don't never get to spend enough
time in
um
another great show and on that one we
had
amy schumer
and she [__] crushed [__] crushed
and uh
yeah i got to work with sarah silverman
i never get to work with her
um
crystalia i never get to work with him i
just it was just [__] awesome
and you know
i had a [__] going after jim jeffries
every night which is jesus christ
[__] guy's one of the best
storytellers i've ever heard and i'm
thinking all right i'm gonna get a night
off because there's a buffer between
[__] him and me and then [__] amy
schumer goes out and absolutely destroys
but it was uh it was a great time uh the
crowds were so well behaved it was it
was [__] awesome and then uh and then
the end of the night i got to hang out
with all these comics uh it's one of the
reasons why i like doing comedy
festivals because you get to hang with
the other comics and stuff chris
hardwick another guy
i worked with i'm trying to remember to
say everybody oh and what's his face uh
stephen brody stevens is the funniest
[__] host ever
he says so much [__] the crowd doesn't
even get and the comics in the back are
[__] dying
he said what the [__] did he say he was
going i'm gonna do a bad impression of
him he's go ladies and gentlemen the
level of comedian you are going to see
tonight
these comedians have been on television
they've been blah blah blah he goes
these comedians own houses
i know i [__] butchered it
but the crowd doesn't even get it
because they're sitting in the the
crowds like
we own houses they don't understand that
most comics
it sucks if you stick with you don't end
up with a house
or you stay in a one-bedroom apartment
but look at me i i [__] i bought a
house when i was 43 years old i finally
got a house
and before then i was you know
in a one-bedroom apartment you're just
terminally in this one-bedroom apartment
waiting for this big break so it was a
really inside [__] joke and uh i
butchered it whatever i um
like we got a great picture that uh
i don't know who the [__] took it i
can't even remember i was drinking so
much this weekend but uh
um
steve and brody stevens used to play uh
like triple a baseball or something or
college level baseball you know that
warm-up thing that they do
when they walk across the field and
they're kicking their foot up into the
air and they're trying to touch their
hands that's above his head he brought
up crystalia and when he was walking off
stage he was doing that
and i and never addressed it never
looked at the crowd somebody took a
picture it's one of the coolest [__]
pictures i've seen i'll i'll retweet it
on the uh the mm podcast at the mm
podcast uh twitter thing but um but
whatever man it was a it was a great
great time and um
you know i don't like where my [__]
act is
uh currently and evidently a few people
in the crowd didn't either
[Laughter]
um
we drove back in the van last night it
was [__] hilarious and we just we all
we were doing was reading the tweets
from people that didn't like us and the
van ride back was one of the funniest
van rides
i had somebody wrote uh bill burr is
killing dot dot dot my buzz
and then said please get off the stage
boo
i had another guy right
um
he tried to claim that i i told the
crowd to go out and murder people
and it [__]
i laughed so hard when i read that it's
just like
what is so funny about doing stand-up is
or just public speaking in general is
the second you get done saying it it's
it's not yours anymore it goes into
people's heads i know i've said this
before but however they hear it is how
they hear it and then they write back to
you with supreme confidence that they
totally understood your intentions
this guy said that i was on stage and i
told the crowd to go out and go murder
people i didn't say that
that completely wasn't my point
um but
i've learned to not i've tried to
anyways learn to not give a [__] and
just be like all right well that just
has to do with
maybe somebody yelled right as i said
that sentence and he didn't hear it or
maybe it's his childhood i don't know
what
but he wrote like you know because i was
retweeting people who said nice things
like hey you really made me laugh i
retweeted that and he wrote to me like
you know hey bill retweet this
maybe like you know
hands on the hips you know with the
fists standing in like superman like so
[__] confident
i actually had to think for half a
second to be like what [__] joke did
i tell that he thought
that that's what i was saying i was like
i know what joke it is yeah it's like
dude i wa and i wanted to write back to
him
like you know or you could
you know pay a little closer attention
to the meaning of the joke but maybe he
was paying attention that's just how we
heard it
but you know what that's not my fault
it's not my fault that you that that's
what you heard i find that a little
bizarre that that's what you thought
um
i hope that whoever wrote that isn't one
of those uh
one of those list people
you know those people that are just kind
of like they got their little list like
okay these these are good words these
are bad words
you know
or not not even like bad just like
there's one context
like if you say this word that means
you're a homophobe if you say this word
that means you're sexist if you if you
feel this way on this subject
uh you're a jesus freak
you're a gun nut uh
you're you're you're a baby murderer
whatever wherever they stand on whatever
[__] issue abortion whatever like
they don't listen
to what you're saying
um and it what it
makes for some really entertaining
tweets
um
i had to save them
i had to save them one time and just
[__] i'd say put out a book but why
do that no one would one would buy it
just [__] you know
save a goddamn tree with this laptop
that probably killed [__] 40 000
trees and i'll just put them all out
there i i got somewhere in my one of my
hard drives i have a bunch of hate mail
i just kept saving them because they
were [__] hilarious
and i was also trying to learn to see
the humor in him because back in the day
i would actually write the people back
and then what you learn after a while is
like you know
you actually kind of await like
validated
you know if what they said is wrong then
just let it go
you know
that's kind of what i've learned just
let it [__] disappear into the abyss
but i gotta tell you they're [__]
hilarious to read
um anyways where are we where are we in
the podcast at this point 36 minutes in
all right i'm gonna go a little short
because it's also my labor day you know
yeah i work so [__] hard don't i
telling jokes
goddamn [__]
what the hell is this labor day i think
i read this every year because i always
forget what it is uh labor day in the
united states for you people around the
world
um is a holiday celebrated on the first
monday in september you know i realized
there's actually somebody who might work
in a sweatshop listening to this going
like beside themselves
you know going like you actually have
the balls
to have a labor day after what the [__]
i do
you know or maybe they used to work
there because if you still work they
probably wouldn't have a laptop
you know they don't allow you to see
things do they
have you guys seen that movie about that
train
that never stops moving with ed harris
not jesus did i just ruin the end of the
movie i'm gonna shut up right now i
think i just ruined the end of the movie
um
labor day in the united states everybody
is a holiday
celebrated on the first monday in
september
it is a celebration of the american
labor movement and is dedicated to the
social and economic achievements of
workers basically they had slave labor
here and we started unions to get out of
it
and then uh the unions for the most part
became what they were fighting and then
the companies left
and uh now we're all in cubicles
uh it constitutes a yearly national
tribute to the contribution workers have
made to the strength prosperity and the
well-being of their country
uh well that's what it is sorry labor
day was from promoted by the central
labor union and the knights of labor who
organized the first parade in new york
city and the haymarket massacre which
occurred in chicago on may 4th 1886 ah
oh well we got to look up this one
this is why you get a decent wage
because these people died
it's [__] unbelievable
protest and how much you make an hour
and you actually take a shovel to the
[__] head
the haymarket affair also known as
the haymarket affair also known as the
haymarket massacre
this is like you know whether which side
of the shovel you were on if you were
the one who killed somebody or sent the
people down to kill the [__]
rabble rousers that was called the the
haymarket affair
and everybody who was there or new
people got killed called it the massacre
and the cops called it the haymarket
riot all right here we go was the
aftermath of a bombing that took place
at a labor demonstration on tuesday the
4th 1886 at haymarket square in chicago
it began as a peaceful rally in support
of the workers striking
for an eight-hour day
and in reaction to the killing of
several workers by the police
uh the previous day that was the shovel
day all right an unknown an unknown
person threw a dynamite bomb at the
police as they acted to disperse that
that's not the way you get your point
heard the bomb blast
oh wait i had this backwards maybe the
the workers called it the affair oh that
if dude it was a lit we had a little
affair you know
you know i was doing that was one
[__] stick though
one stick
whatever dude they should be on our side
so then i would say that the the cops
called it the massacre
and also see that this is the great
thing about me is i don't read and i
just form a [__] opinion and then i
wade into the swamp i don't think it's
that deep
um
the bomb blast in the ensuing gunfire
resulted in the deaths of seven police
officers and at least four civilians
scores of others were wounded
and that's not a good time to get
wounded either in 1886 jesus christ
um so anyways yeah so
who knows that and now it's just this
day that we sit around and we we take a
day off and you listen to some [__]
[__] do a podcast
um all right anyways let's get to the uh
to the wonderful questions this week oh
oh oh [__] oh [__]
here we go i actually have a um
a big promotion here for a good friend
of mine
joe derosa
also known
as the teen idol sensation from the
opium anthony program aka
joey roses aka roses aka joey d
um
aka shoulderless joe
all right joe derosa has a new album
coming out digitally on tuesday
september 2nd that is tomorrow if you're
listening to it on september 1st or it's
yesterday if you listen to it on
wednesday the third
or it was seven years ago and you
finally discovered me how are you in the
future am i still alive
um on tuesday september 2nd
and it's called mistakes were made this
is actually a really cool idea uh
mistakes were made the b sides it's a
double disc of unreleased material
recorded at various places over the last
seven years it's essentially joe's
version of rarities that a band would
put out
uh i think that's cool as hell and i'll
tell you right now i for one i know what
i'm doing tomorrow september 2nd
downloading that album
then congratulating my good buddy joe
derosa
for a job well done all right leaked
photos
billy gatekeeper
the internet almost exploded sunday
because a massive dump of hacked nude
pictures of celebrities
yes it is a violation of trust yes it
would be immoral to post or spread but
my question to you is
what if you were the 9 to 5 or even
worse night shift guy that doesn't have
a lot going on no girlfriend no future
how was it how was not looking at them
making the world better or preventing it
from being an issue
so let's break this down millions of us
see jennifer lawrence nude but guy with
nine to five doesn't
does that change anything
i don't understand your question here
millions of people they're saying
i get i i missed on out in the store so
i guess they were leaked millions of
people saw him and now they're saying
out of respect for her you don't look at
him so the guy with the nine to five
just hears about it should he not look
at it
um
does it change anything well it would be
nice if people respected people's
privacy i mean that
you got to understand that all of us by
being on the internet you got a tiger by
the tail
and um
i never liked that cloud thing i always
thought it was
i didn't like that they had my photos
even if they don't leak somebody has
them and somebody can look at them
you know
it's like i mean not like i'm taking
pictures of my dick or something i mean
i don't know why i would do that
that's [__] weird
um
but it's just you know family photos and
just
private photos of where i am and what
i'm doing like all of that type of stuff
yeah i think that's really weird and um
i don't know i don't like any of this
[__] i don't like doing anything that's
why i don't bank online even though i
know all my information my all my
information is online just in case i
want a bank online which is [__]
hilarious to me i don't think that that
should be legal i think they should have
had to clear that with me
because
anything that is online is compromised
there's no such thing as a secure site
all there is is more secure
so um
i don't know i would like to think that
you wouldn't do it
i'm not gonna do it she's mortified she
there's plenty of naked women out there
on the internet that are doing it and
making money off of it and want to do it
just respect your privacy and don't do
it you wouldn't want somebody doing that
to you
um
not that anybody give a [__] seeing you
naked but whatever that that version of
it is
you wouldn't want somebody to hack into
your bank account take all your money
and that type of [__] you know
um i feel bad for her i uh
you know but i mean
hopefully everybody stops using the
cloud i think i actually inadvertently
am using i am on the cloud now i see
that little icon and i don't ever
remember signing up for it
granted i suck at these things but uh i
don't know
i don't know
it's it's very
strange and i just think the further we
go into the future the less and less
privacy there's going to be and rather
than people thinking about it in a
rational way
in a human way
it's just going to be a bunch of
screaming and yelling
um which kind of seems to be what all
debate is now it's screaming and yelling
it's not
listening to
another person's point of view
having an ability to be swayed
trying to hear where they're coming from
it's all about just getting out your
point of view talking over somebody and
hyping your [__] went you know that
split screen [__]
where you know they're gonna debate
something and then the two people just
start yelling at each other and whoever
yelled louder
i guess wins
i don't know
it's kind of like those [__] google
glasses like if those things ever take
off
the fact that someone can then walk
around
and just be randomly filming people and
converse like all privacy is gone
and i know even though you're out in
public but you know
you know you're you should just be
interacting with who you're interacting
with
you know right then and there like to to
then take it to and well you're in
public so now what i share it with the
world
that's i don't know i i i am not looking
forward to that aspect
of uh
of the future
you know what i mean
i i that that [__] to me is all [__]
creepy all right so here we go next one
uh dollar bills dear dollar bills
what's your favorite form of currency
i'm a huge fan of 20s what bill best
represents you oh man dude i like the
hundred dollar bill
100 bills the [__] nothing but yeah
you see old ben's [__] face
you got a couple of those in your wallet
that's my favorite i like that and i
like the five
i like the five bucks
i like lincoln i just like the way it
looks i've always liked the lincoln
memorial
um the 50s weird
i really like a uh
i like the hundred dollar bill and i'm
fascinated with the 500 bill and the
thousand dollar bill
like
where can you get those can i go down to
the bank and like withdraw a thousand
bucks and say yeah can i get that in a
just get one thousand dollar bill that's
what i want i'm sorry i said we don't
have any well that's how i want it
but then what happens
do they have to go get it
you know like you like this well it's
like it's a special order car and i
gotta wait three months for the factory
to build it like how does that work
who uses thousand dollar bills
that's got to be done like when we're
doing some dirty deal
arms for hostages you got that [__]
briefcase there has to be a bunch of
thousand dollar bills in there
you know what i mean
i don't know but i would say i like the
hundred you have a hundred dollar bill
you feel you just you just you just
become more generous
no no no i got it i got it you [__]
take it out you slam it down on the
table twenty dollar bill you're playing
a little closer to the chest you know
i only got 20 of these things i got a
hundred
who wants some potato skits
all right comedy tour billy the king
looks like uh
you're having fun on the oddball tour i
had a great time could not have had a
better time please tell us a funny story
or a joke from the tour i think i
already did that we saw you wheeling
sarah
in the crystalia picture on twitter
oh yeah yeah yeah i'll retweet that one
on the uh the mm podcast too
i don't even know how that happened she
was just sick of walking through that
giant airport
so she was trying to like
you know she was making us laugh she was
trying to almost like treat it like how
you'd lay down on a skateboard she had
this giant bag that she was a
check bag
so she started going on it and she was
slowing down i just sort of grabbed it
and started walking with it she was like
this is the [__] greatest way to go
through an airport
she loved it
and then crystalia took a picture of us
and even though we were having a lot of
fun what's funny about the picture
we were laughing was it looks like we
we're a couple that just got arraigned
for something shady and now we're
walking out of court and we're just
trying to get past the press like you
know that face people have
with when after they get arraigned for
they haven't been acquitted they haven't
been they haven't been convicted they
just got arraigned like this is what we
are accusing you of and this is the time
you are facing that [__] look
um i could never have that look on my
face and he caught me between emotions
i think my inner thought was like am i
gonna be in this picture i don't think
i'm in this picture
there you go is that funny enough i
don't know made me laugh he said if you
were going to put together a comedy tour
of only deceased comics and you were the
host who would you pick keep in mind you
have chaplain up there to lean into the
wind
or abbott and cassel costello for some
who's on first [__]
legendary bit uh they're all dead so
you're not pissing anyone off
um
all right well i'm not going to talk
about any of my dead friends because
that's too [__] sad so i will talk
about uh
charlie chaplin to do a stand-up show
i'd still have him coming out i don't
know i i've become a huge fan of his i
like i never had the patience to sit
down and watch one of his movies and i
was in uh
when i was in montreal i sat down and i
had breakfast by myself
sat up at the bar and uh jesus bill even
at breakfast you're at a bar absolutely
um
and they had it on in the background and
because it's silent you know i didn't
have to listen to any
dialogue and i was actually able to
follow it and
i really got into the whole character of
the [__] what a piece of [__] he was
and he was always having problems with
the cops and running into shady
characters he's always going up and down
the alleys and stuff i
i just like i like this guy you know so
yeah i'd have him on there i had buster
keaton
you gotta have wc fields at some point
my chickadee had him coming out there
being all grumpy and [__]
um
all the other obvious ones that you'd
know
pryor carlin kinnison hicks all of those
guys
man i guess i you know i guess the
obvious ones
red fox
you know oh speaking of which um
by the way uh
yeah it sucks about joan rivers right
now man
she doesn't get a [__] do you watch
it's unfortunate if she actually
passes away which i hope doesn't happen
um there's no way to not put her top
five top six all [__] time for some
reason
you know
she hasn't gotten her credit
i i don't understand why and for the
love of [__] christ i don't want to
listen to the [__] woman issue again
there's plenty of people that don't get
that [__] dude but i'm sure with her
because it was way back in the day i'm
sure there was an element of that but
i'm [__] exhausted with that [__]
topic
um
but anyway yeah she's like top [__]
six
seven all times five like where if you
put her in top five all time abso
[__] lutely
absolutely like
i think she's like she doesn't put out
specials she's just on that [__]
fashion channel [__] on people's
dresses but if you actually put it on
and you listen to the jokes that she's
doing it's just like that they're
[__] unbelievable
who's telling me a joke
i think sarah told me this weekend she
had a joke
it was a joke about woody allen
it was something about
somebody when i'm gonna [__] the whole
joke up
it was something about you know what you
take karate and you're a yellow belt
and she did some sort of joke about
the last time something yellow became
came in between woody and uh whatever
the mia pharaoh
it was a reference to the karate belt
and that he has an asian wife
i completely butchered it jesus christ i
didn't even back into that joke i just
[__]
threw that thing into the chipper
um
but it's just that's the type of [__] i
can never get away with that [__]
joke
um
so anyways
i don't know i i
i really hope she [__] pulls through
man
it's a [__] legend and a half
and uh all you guys want to be tough on
twitter and be like what was the big
deal you [__] 81. i i get it i get it
you're edgy
all right back to school hello mr burr
i'm about to start start my sophomore
year of high school soon and i want to
know if you can give me some advice
yeah don't do what i did
i said my grades were pretty good last
year so that really isn't a problem dude
that's [__] huge
keep your grades up
keep your options wide open
unlike mine that [__] closed
immediately uh for this upcoming year uh
also also the whatever the grades aren't
a problem for this upcoming year but the
girls of my school are i have no problem
making friends in both genders but i
can't really seal the deal with the
ladies i know i am young and probably
shouldn't not be worrying about sex
yet but his hor but as a horny teenager
oh jesus christ
please tell me this is a guy
he said i feel the need
all he said with women but you know you
never know i said i feel the need to at
least try and get laid i can't seem to
be taken seriously by girls in my school
they seem to think i'm just a comedian
and not a possible sexual partner
any advice on how to get with these
girls any advice is appreciated and i
know you get a lot of advice questions
so thank you very much for reading this
ah god damn it he went respectful i love
your stanford podcast you're filming
blah blah blah the heat breaking bad
thank you i appreciate all that um i
didn't get laid in high school so i
you're asking you're barking up the
wrong [__] tree i was i was you
i was you i was making my friends laugh
but i didn't have i didn't have women
friends either
so you're further along than i am so i
actually asked you how did you do that
i wasn't even like
oh dude it was a [__] barren
wasteland
my my childhood was overloaded
testosterone so overloaded that like i
don't even like
you know i am just getting like my views
and understanding on women
at 46
like i should have been plowing through
this at like 19
um
i just as far as understanding how where
they're coming from
so uh
what what can what advice can i give you
um
um stop being friends with with women ah
see bad advice like i wouldn't do that
there's that there's that whole [__]
bit chris rock did where if you stay
friends with him too long they view you
that way and then
looking at you as a sexual partner
becomes gross
um
so what is this deal i'm not gonna go
negative stay friends with the women
you're friends with
all right
but don't become friends with any other
ones
hit on all the other ones
all right if you're out if you're in a
really small [__] pond
go to a [__] party the next town over
and be the mysterious guy from the other
town although if there's football
players there they might just beat the
[__] out of you at least that's what
would happen when i was a kid so watch
out for that [__]
um
i don't know
i would say the upside is that college
is only two years away college is only
two years away and this is the deal
you're going to be thinking back all the
[__] women that you could have
[__] been having fun with
um so you just you got to put it out
there man i think that that's what
you're doing i think you're being like
uh yeah you don't know how to [__]
get into that traffic pattern you know
you're just sort of circling the [__]
you're in a holding pattern here man you
got you got to try to come in for a
landing
and uh i would say any girl that you are
friends with
it's [__] over
don't even try to hook up with them
don't wear them out
all right
i would actually you know what i would
do a couple of them i would talk to them
i would talk to them you know what if
you're friends with them they'll try and
hook you up with some other girl
who they'll see is like well you know
she wants to meet a boy
that's there you go that might be the
way to get in there
hey nia
can you help this kid get laid
this is beyond
this is beyond my realm
it's it's a it's a [__] it's a it's a
kid in high school
some kid in high school he he has no
problem making friends he's doing well
in school he has a lot of female friends
but he can't seem to get past that so
he's asking me how does he get laid as a
sophomore in high school i was like i
didn't get sophomore in high school well
whatever hook up you know get him in the
game he wants some at bats
all right so young and cute
he doesn't need to he doesn't want to be
cute this guy wants to be a badass he's
got marlboro man here you got to build
this dude up so so he he's friends with
a lot of women so me like a [__] you
know what i said i said first thing you
got to do don't be friends with any more
women and i immediately heard your voice
in my head going you're such a [__]
[__] so i was like all right scratch
that
so i came up with
don't try to hook up with any of the
girls you're friends with because
they've already stopped looking at you
like you're a sexual being it's going to
seem gross in the friend zone yeah the
chris rock classic chris rock the friend
zone so
i said
a couple of them that you feel like you
can trust
just kind of put it out there like hey
you know girl girls just you you you
play uh you back away like hey you know
girls they don't want to hook up with me
they oh gee they just look at me like
i'm just funny and then they'll be like
what are you talking about you have a
lot to offer and then i think that
they'll maybe hook him up
with some other girl that they know that
is probably maybe saying the same [__]
yeah but he probably knows all those
girls though
i feel like he's got to move outside his
circle of uh the girls that he's friends
with i mean if he wants to sort of be
like do you guys think i'm i don't know
do some sort of like
i don't know what am i cool am i like do
you think girls would want to like date
me because i just feel like you know you
can't say am i cool once you say am i
cool you're not cool anymore well i
suggested i suggested that he go to
another town but i'm worried he's going
to run into the town
yeah be the mysterious guy where are you
from huh the next town over you should
see our 7-eleven baby if there's a girl
that he likes he should just go up and
just start talking to her but just make
it clear not by being like i want to
date you or i want to [__] you because
i'm looking to get not like that but
just like oh that's bad yeah
just start like you know just being
funny and and and all that kind of stuff
and just being cool with her but
definitely like you got to put up the
flirtatious vibe that's what it is it's
all about properly flirting you know
what i mean and not like lingering too
long with it and not like oh can i you
know just showing up at her locker you
know in between classes already there
like hey
so going to algebra huh like not like
that lingering's bad i learned that the
hard way were you a lingerer
and i was quiet so i look like a psycho
creepy yeah definitely
i could see that i could definitely see
that being your uh your thing oh when i
was younger my thing like i'm a [__]
creep i didn't know what to do i was i
was old billy freckles i wasn't i was a
man without a country you just gotta
just flirt with them just be cute with
them give them a compliment don't go too
overboard with it you know even if it's
just something like you know all right
i'm going to give you two compliments
sally you know like nice dress keep
moving
and keeping hey sally nice dress he's
got to give him something better than
that
i'm not really good at this okay because
i feel like it's like a natural thing
that you have it's all about you know
what it is i think i think once you're
secure with yourself
and you're not feeling those
feelings of inadequacy
that's when that kind of natural swag
can happen you can't manufacture it so
that's why me trying to give him like
lines to throw out sounds ridiculous
because they're completely manufactured
yeah and also you're a woman so you
don't have to like hit on people
you just show up and look cute that's
why yeah we've been through this before
i'm not getting into it again that's why
at your
cute age your opening line is hey sally
nice dress
i know that really wasn't terrible
but but just give out a compliment and
keep it moving that's all can you come
up with a middle ground between uh hey
sally nice dress and hey uh sally nice
[__] wreck what what'd i say
i don't think that i can
just make it something like you know
just offhanded
you know oh that's cool what's that or
did i just ask about something about her
you know
what's that book you're reading i'm
trying to put it in context of like a
school type of situation so it's not
completely out of left field you know
what you're good at starting the car
getting in right hey what's that book
you're reading and then she's got to be
like um
[__] harry potter and then you're
like yeah
saw that movie
that's pretty pretty cool
oh god i'm the worst and then your face
turns all red
well the thing about it is too is we're
talking about teenagers here so i don't
know that this is this is [__] creepy
we're a long
ways away from being like in high school
so i can't even like go back there
mentally to figure out how
a boy that age would talk to a girl i
have no idea because i can't i can't
remember anything
previous to insult her a little bit
like that that's how i always stay down
negging is that what it's called yeah
tearing them down
no not tearing them down but just giving
them [__] in a funny way
yeah well that's all yeah that can be
cute for sure t is like a playful
teasing yeah but it's like you got to
know the person well enough to do that
you know what i mean it's like if it's
some girl that he hasn't talked to
in like three years and all of a sudden
he's like yeah [__]
like she's gonna be like what who's that
yeah
that's the worst i've learned all these
lessons what was that
did i ever tell you i feel like it's
less about here's my here's my final
thought on it i think it's less about oh
shut up i think it's less about how do i
get the girls to like me
yeah i did why'd you tell me to shut up
your face was was saying things no
because like no i didn't like what your
face was saying to me so i told her to
shut up i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you
what my i was imitating a woman's face
when i said something to her one time
that was the face she made at me what do
you mean what did you say
uh you know i was in between
relationships you remember just spit it
out no because it's embarrassing i was
in between relationships and all these
comics were just like dude just you know
just [__] say it and blah blah blah
blah and just stay single and just bang
a bunch of broads and blah blah blah so
i tried to be that guy
so and it was sort of working for me and
then i just one night it just completely
backfired i was at danger field and this
woman came up to me and told me how much
she liked
my you know blah blah blah started the
small talk and everything and then i
tried to be you know leather jacket guy
said hey you want to just cut through
the [__] i mean i live right up the
street if you want to come
and she goes she just went like what huh
no no i and she slowly backed away and i
was like
i [__]
it took me slow it bb you blew it there
was nothing to blow it was just [__]
it wasn't even there there was no
situation i completely
i misread the whole thing i feel like
this kid has got to just get his his
confidence and his own personal swag
going that's all it is it's like i feel
like it's not about the other people so
much is about how you feel about
yourself
you know and i but i feel like that's
also like a concept that's kind of hard
for people that you know what dude
you're going to figure it out just keep
[__] trying say hi just say hi hey
how's it going and keep moving that's
what i feel like you know how you're
talking about the mystery that's way
better than hi hi sally nice dress
i know
that was the [__] worst advice ever
you know
judging by your skills and some of the
[__] that i said back in the day i don't
know how we ever [__] met how do we
make it well i make because i think
we're both you know
it's just nerds
all right beat it i gotta read the
advertising and wrap this up i thought
you were wrapping it up early
i am i but i i gotta i gotta do the
advertising here
stamps.com everybody
here's a big dilemma for the week
everybody
dilemma dear billy the bakers man big
fan first time writer or first time to
write dedicated listener for over three
years i have an age-old dilemma for you
i have been engaged for about five
months to the perfect woman for me about
two weeks ago she received a text after
10 pm from a male co-worker
oh
geez
like the mature man that i am i passed
it off as nothing and kindly reminded
her that text after 10 p.m should only
be for emergencies or naughty talk
between the two of us she agreed i work
out of town five days a week oh
jj
so i'm not there every night
a few days ago she texts me that she's
going to dinner with the same gal
jg dude what the [__]
the same guy just the two of them and
they're going to the same restaurant as
our first date
jesus christ dude
i can't even read the rest of this text
there's so many red flags flapping in my
face i hope i'm not right she explained
that they invited other co-workers but
everyone declined or bailed
uh
okay and if she did the same thing she
would be cool with that
i wouldn't be cool with this
man or woman would not be cool with this
this is not because i'm trying to see is
this like a
a female thing and a guy doesn't
understand this is not a cool this is
not cool
i tell her that this does not make me
mad but i am not happy about it either
she describes this guy as short single
and dates around
yeah he's trying to bang her one more
time before she gets married that's what
he's doing i'm not saying that's what
your fiance is doing but that's what
he's doing
the [__] he going there for
conversation the guy who dates around
um ever since that night and of course
my dissatisfaction for the event that
occurred things have been slightly
touchy between us i trust this girl but
i could never trust a single guy
i have i had issues with women and guy
friends in the past my parents divorced
when i was young due to infidelity and
i've never been 100 percent trusting of
women
am i wrong to think that this is
inappropriate for an engaged or married
woman to go out to dinner
let's face it it's a date with a single
man or vice versa
oh yeah abso [__] lootly
abso-fucking-lootly
and the timing of this too well you're
engaged and you're gonna get married
it's like
yeah i'd be like listen if if you want
out just say so
just rip the band-aid off take my heart
throw across the [__] room into the
garbage disposal right now let's just
[__] get this over with because
uh
yeah dude that is a uh that that is not
that is not cool
that's not a cool situation
um
yeah so i agree with you you haven't
really asked me anything but i 100 agree
with you that is not
that's not cool that's a really shitty
position for her to put you in
um
and i've been that piece of [__] other
guy too so i know what his [__]
intentions are
so there you go
there's that
um
i don't know what to tell you
that's one of those things where like
you got to say you can't ever do that
again but then there's also that thing
like i shouldn't have to tell you not to
do that
um
and that's a hell of a [__] tale that
they invited all of these other people
and they all declined that sounds like a
really bad lie
um
oh jesus christ what is that expression
about a woman's heart
about the secrets it holds
i shouldn't i shouldn't quote this
because you'll never trust them
um
who's getting who you can't [__]
trust anybody
let me let me just google this woman's
heart
secrets
see if it comes up
the women's heart
secrets
new woman's heart program the woman's
heart secret
a woman's heart is a deep ocean of
secrets
there it is
ah it didn't take too long
holy [__]
i'm [__] believable
that's amazing is that true you know the
step that's why i never believe in
stereotypes because they always say
women can never shut the [__] up they
can't keep a secret and they're always
gossiping
maybe they keep their secrets
maybe i should shut the [__] up and i've
said enough dumb things for the week
what do you i think so enjoy the rest of
your labor day all right that's the
podcast for this week god bless alia
thank you everybody came out to the um
the oddball tour thank you for everybody
who tweeted that they liked me thank you
even more to the people said they didn't
like me
uh they were [__] hilarious
and uh that's it go [__] yourselves i'll
talk to you next week
you